eine gewisse Faszination für das Böse
teilt auch der Philosoph Jörg Noller der
seit kurzem in Basel lebt er hat schon
drei Bücher zu dem Thema geschrieben was
sagt es denn über uns als Gesellschaft
aus dass wir uns quasi am Leid anderer
ergötzen und daraus fast eine Industrie
entwickelt haben gesagt aus dass wir
viel Spannung brauchen dass wir
unterhalten werden wollen und wir fühlen
uns vom Bösen einerseits angezogen aber
auch abgestoßen und wir können uns auch
durch diese Anziehung und Abstoßung
häufig besser kennenlernen wir erleben
uns auch neu und intensiver weil wir uns
auch vielleicht manchmal in gewisse
Hinsicht mit den Täterinnen und Tätern
identifizieren könnte man auch sagen es
ist eine Möglichkeit der eigenen
moralischen Überhöhung quasi in dem wir
auf dem Sofa sitzen und anderen Menschen
dabei zu sehen wie sie fundamentale
Regeln der Gesellschaft missachten und
da sitzen und sagen aber wir sind die
meisten besseren Menschen und moralisch
überlegen das finde ich eine zutreffend
die Analyse man könnte das auch schöne
Form von Erhabenheit nennen wir tun es
nicht aber wir erleben es trotzdem mit
und in dieser Spannung einerseits
angezogen zu sein von dem Bösen sich
aber andererseits auch moralisch davon
distanzieren zu können zur selben Zeit
darin besteht glaube ich einer der
vielen Reize diese sendungsformats